let's talk about the massive leaks I
mean just massive massive leaks that are
being called the Paradise Papers Appleby
is a bermuda based law firm and they
sent a significant amount of leaks to a
German newspaper that newspaper shared
the leaks with the international
consortium of investigative journalists
which is a global network that was they
actually won a Pulitzer for their work
on the Panama papers and these new leaks
are an explosion of Trump Russia
revelations which could end up playing a
major role in Robert Moeller's
investigation Wilbur Ross is the
Commerce Secretary we learned two things
from the leaks one Wilbur Ross has an
interest in a shipping company called
the navigator holdings which does huge
business in fact it's most important
business arguably is with a Russian
energy firm controlled by help you're
sitting down
Vladimir Putin's son-in-law and other
Putin inner circle members navigator
Holdings is also connected to sabor
which is a huge Russian petrochemical
company that's part one okay part two is
Wilbur Ross failed to disclose those
interests in and on his disclosure forms
when being confirmed for the position of
Secretary of Commerce now I'm not a
lawyer as many of you know I remind Pat
every day that I'm not a lawyer he
forgets but isn't a Commerce Secretary
lying about being business partners with
Vladimir Putin's immediate family sort
of something we should be concerned
about and of course the idea that he can
just divest and everything's fine that's
also ridiculous because he'd still know
how trade policies and regulations and
sanctions would affect his previous
business partners even if he on paper
divested and he did say he'd divest he
said he would recuse himself as
necessary but he never disclosed or
explained the interests that he kept
that's Wilbur Ross and the Paradise
Papers let's move on to Jared Kushner
Trump's son-in-law husband of Ivanka
Trump maybe our next winner in Russia
indictment bingo as I'm calling it the
papers that have been recently released
reveal that Russian entrepreneur Yuri
Milner
invested close to a million dollars
Jared Kushner startup called cadre and
the real news isn't that he actually
made the investments in an American
company it's that the documents reveal
that Milner himself is also Kremlin
connected which was not known until now
a Kremlin owned Bank invested nearly two
hundred million dollars into one of
milliner's companies and remember Jared
Kushner told the Senate Intelligence
Committee behind closed with closed
doors he never relied on Russian money
for his businesses and I guess the word
reliance is a weasel word right what
does it mean to rely if one Russian
source went away would your business
fail or does real I mean that if they
bailed you would be able to find other
revenue sources that's going to be the
spin right oh yeah no Russian companies
invested but we weren't reliant on their
money but it's even worse with Kushner
over the last couple months we've
learned of Russian spending or maybe we
would call it investments using Twitter
and Facebook ads the Paradise Papers
expose that the Kremlin invested
hundreds of millions of dollars not in
ad spending but in the corporations
Twitter and Facebook through a business
associate of Jared Kushner named Yuri
Milner the same guy last week I told you
that Twitter offered 15% of their
election advertising to Russian state
media arty and we wondered why would
they do that but why would they do it so
cheaply just three million dollars for
15% of their ads of all election
advertising maybe this is why we don't
know the pieces are starting to come
together and as a reminder we already
know from months ago that the Secretary
of State Rex Tillerson the top diplomat
of the United States he has been
confirmed by prior leaked documents to
have been the director of a u.s. Russian
oil company based in the Bahamas which
is a total tax haven folks believe me so
who isn't connected to Russia in sketchy
ways that works for Donald Trump maybe
will we will eventually get an answer to
that from Robert Moeller's investigation
we're on reddit david pakman.com slash
read it check it out back after this
today's program is made possible in part
by zip
Bruder if you're hiring you must know
where to post your job to find the best
candidates and hiring can be easier and
more streamlined and less time-consuming
with zip recruiter and you've got to be
able to reach the quality hires that
will keep your business moving forward
but you don't want to sink endless
amounts of time into finding the right
person with zip recruiter you can post
your job to over a hundred job sites
with just one click
then zip recruiter will put its smart
matching technology to work it will
notify qualified candidates about your
job within minutes of posting and
ideally you will then start receiving
possible matches for the job you've
listed that's why zip recruiter is not
like other hiring sites the zip
recruiter doesn't depend on the
righthand that it's finding you it will
find the right candidates and put you in
touch with them
no wonder 80% of employers who post on
zip recruiter get quality candidates
within the site in just one day no
juggling emails no juggling calls to
your office you can screen rate and
manage candidates all in one place with
zip recruiters dashboard this is the
smartest way to hire find out today why
zip recruiter has been used by
businesses of all sizes and industries
to find the most qualified job
candidates with immediate results and
our listeners and viewers can post jobs
on zip recruiter for free free that's
zip recruiter dot-com slash PA KMA and
one more time to try it for free go to
zip recruiter dot-com slash PA KMA n